a successful movie can spawn off a
sequel or potentially an entire
franchise usually that means most of the
cast is asked to return but some were
not there's plenty of reasons these
actors got axed from these movies
it's one thing to miss out on a sequel
that flops and inevitably goes nowhere
it's another thing to sit out a
follow-up that opens the door to one of
the largest most ambitious franchises in
movie history alas that is the premise
of The Ballad of Terence Howard when
Robert Downey Jr first put on his Iron
Man suit in 2008 Howard was by his side
as James Rose Tony Stark's close friend
and future War Machine yet two years
later when Stark was called on once
again to save the world Rhodey looked a
lot less like Terence Howard and a lot
more like Don Cheadle in the end cheetah
would go on to play Roadie War Machine
throughout the Marvel Cinematic Universe
right up through the 2023 Disney plus
series secret Invasion while Howard has
a reputation for being difficult to work
with the actor said in interviews that
his disappearance from the ncu had
nothing to do with his attitude instead
he blamed his co-star
that the person that I helped become
Iron Man took the money that was
supposed to go to me and
pushed me out Howard elaborated further
on the sway in the morning radio show
explaining that instead of paying him
the 8 million dollars he was originally
offered for Iron Man 2 Marvel arranged
to pay him just 1 million way back in
the infancy of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe the studio released the
Incredible Hulk starring Oscar nominee
Edward Norton the movie wasn't quite the
smash hit that many of its MCU
successors would be but it was received
markedly better than Ang Lee's Hulk
nevertheless when it came time to
integrate the big green guy into the
rest of the MCU in The Avengers it was
Mark Ruffalo in the role of Bruce Banner
while plenty of disputes over actors
returning to sequels involve money this
conflict seems decidedly tilted toward
creative differences Norton was an
uncredited writer on the project and he
along with the film's director pushed
for a version of the movie that was
around 135 minutes
Studio was more interested in a leaner
cut and won out with a 112 minute
version that may have been one of the
reasons Norton refused to do much
promotion for the film though the actor
claims he prefers to let his movies
speak for themselves in the end it was
more than the execs at Marvel Studios
were willing to put up with in
explaining why the studio moved on from
Norton the president of Marvel Studios
Kevin feige said our decision is
definitely not one based on monetary
factors but instead rooted in the need
for an actor who embodies the creativity
and collaborative Spirit of our other
talented cast members there's no eye in
team and apparently no Norton either
Alec Baldwin already had a number of
television and movie credits on his
resume before signing on to star in The
Hunt for Red October in 1990 but it was
the role of Jack Ryan that helped Propel
him to a new level of stardom with Tom
Clancy writing so prolifically about the
CIA analyst turned field agent one would
have thought that Baldwin was primed to
reprise the role in any number of
sequels but when Patriot Games premiered
in 1992 it was Harrison Ford not Alec
Baldwin in the role of Jack Ryan
Ford would play Ryan again two years
later in Clear and Present Danger before
ceding the role to Ben Affleck in the
sum of all fears so what happened if
Baldwin is to be believed he was run off
as a way for the movie studio to clear a
debt in 2011 the actor wrote that the
reason he never appeared in Patriot
Games is that Paramount Studios owed
money to a very famous movie star after
a previous film deal fell apart so in
order to fulfill his financial
obligation Baldwin was pushed aside
while the famous movie star is never
named some have connected the dots to
Harrison Ford for his part David
Kirkpatrick the executive Baldwin
accused of engineering the move chalked
it up to quote an issue of script
approval sometimes actors are completely
caught by surprise when they don't get
invited back for a sequel such was the
case with Rachelle Lefevre who was on
the outside looking in when the cast for
The Twilight Saga Eclipse was announced
lefeff played the relatively minor role
of Victoria in the first two films of
the series it was expected that the
character would have a larger part in
the story for the third film but Bryce
Dallas Howard wound up taking lefevre's
place the move left LeFevre stunned
according to a statement the actor says
that the decision was made over a
scheduling conflict in which another
part would overlap with the shooting
schedule for Eclipse by 10 days LeFevre
said that she was completely dedicated
to the role of Victoria and didn't
believe that the minor overlap should
have caused a problem the studio didn't
take kindly to lefevre's portrayal of
what happened and released a statement
of its own claiming the actor wasn't
being cooperative whatever the full
story was it certainly meant Twilight
time on lefevre's run in a huge movie
franchise
were it not for the Intrepid reporting
of April O'Neil the world might have
never learned of the existence of the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles at least if
you believe the comic book lore April
O'Neil was played by Judith Hogue in the
1990 debut movie at the time Hogue was a
22 year old actor working alongside
Robin Williams in Cadillac Man and
looking for her big break despite not
knowing what Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles was about she took the role and
worked a dual schedule to finish both
movies but when it came time to cast
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles The Secret
of the Ooze Hogue wasn't invited back
her schedule likely had something to do
with it but not in the way one might
think will I ever see you guys again who
complained to the producers about the
long Six-Day shooting schedule as well
as the film's heavy violence she told
variety I think they thought I was too
demanding and moved on in her place
Paige Turco took over the role although
Hogue was considered for the third film
in the series producers thought it might
be too confusing for young viewers way
back at the turn of the century McGee
who at the time was best known for
directing music videos got his first
turn at directing a feature film the
result was a new millennium reboot of
the wildly popular 70s action drama
Charlie's Angels starring Drew Barrymore
Cameron Diaz and Lucy Liu While most
moviegoers came for the three leads one
of the highlights of the film was comedy
veteran Bill Murray in the role of
Bosley the Angel's desk bound Handler
but when the band got back together in
2003 for Charlie's Angels Full Throttle
Murray was noticeably absent instead
comedian Bernie Mac stepped into the
role with the explanation that he was
the adopted brother of the previous
Bosley off-screen however it was more
complicated than just wanting to make
the sequel a family affair rumors
swirled that Murray clashed with co-star
Lucy Liu leading him to decide that he
no longer wanted to work with the actor
however in the years since the film both
Murray and Lou have thrown cold water on
that story with the former saying it was
an onset argument that was blown out of
proportion
the story that seems to have more legs
is that Murray and director McGee butted
heads literally Murray denies that the
two had a physical altercation though he
did have some strong things to say about
the director
Dee Larson's Millennium Trilogy of books
featuring The exploits of Swedish hacker
Lizbeth Salander was an international
phenomenon in their native country the
books were adapted into a well-received
movie trilogy with numera pass in the
lead role an American remake was
inevitable and Rooney Mara was cast
alongside Daniel Craig in director David
Fincher's 2011 adaptation of The Girl
with the Dragon Tattoo
the movie earned overall positive
reviews pulled in over 230 million
dollars worldwide at the box office and
earned Mara an Oscar nomination however
venture did not return to helm the 2018
sequel the girl in the spider's web and
fide Alvarez took his place nonetheless
many expected Mara and Craig to return
to their respective roles instead
Alvarez decided to go in a different
direction with both of the main
characters he cast Claire Foy and Sara
goodnesson in the lead roles telling ew
I just didn't like the idea of taking
someone else's cast in the end the movie
didn't resonate with either critics or
audiences when director Tim Burton
brought Batman to the big screen in 1989
audiences flocked to see Michael
Keaton's dark knight battle Jack
Nicholson's Joker through the gritty
streets of Gotham City veteran actor
Billy D Williams appeared on screen as
Gotham district attorney Harvey Dent
giving fans reason to assume that he
would become the villain Two-Face in
Burton's subsequent films unfortunately
that never happened at least not with
Williams in the role when Burton's
Batman Returns arrived in 1992 Harvey
Dent was nowhere to be found instead
Batman battled the penguin with Catwoman
thrown into the mix Burton eventually
parted ways with a franchise following
the box office disappointment of Batman
Returns and Jill Schumacher who was
tapped to direct Batman Forever decided
to go a different direction instead of
Williams He recruited Tommy Lee Jones to
Don the makeup for Two-Face and that's
what I wanted to do I wanted to see what
I could do with it it would have been
different than Tommy Elise I got my own
kind of Madness
while Williams never got the chance to
play the role in live action the story
does have a fairly happy ending in
2017's the Lego Batman movie he was cast
as the voice of Two-Face he was also
portrayed as the classic villain in the
comic book series Batman 89. over the
course of the Harry Potter series many
characters were recast for various
reasons most notably rape finds took
over for Richard bremmer when Voldemort
evolved from a disembodied face to a
full-body dark lord and Michael gambin
replaced the deceased Richard Harris as
Dumbledore
one of the less discussed changes was
with the fat lady who guarded the
entrance to the Gryffindor common rail
in Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone
Elizabeth Spriggs played the role it was
a bit of a surprising choice for a
character that was beloved by fans for
being brassy and vivacious Spriggs was
more known for supporting matriarchal
roles in dramas like Sense and
Sensibility perhaps that was part of the
reason director Alfonso Quran decided to
cast boisterous British comedian Don
French in the role when he took over to
make Harry Potter and the Prisoner of
Azkaban Michael J fox may have been the
star of Back to the Future but Crispin
Glover gave a career-defining
performance as George McFly that made it
all the more surprising when Glover
didn't return for either of the movie's
two sequels for any moviegoers asking
why the Elder McFly was portrayed by a
different actor in Back to the Future
Part 2 and part 3 the reason is likely
because Glover himself was asking too
many questions according to Glover he
had a problem with the ending of the
original film saying it sent the message
that money equals happiness a contention
that supposed the anger director Robert
zemegis nevertheless the actor claims he
was still interested in being in the
sequels but the paycheck was much less
than what he considered to be fair
apparently playing George McFly was not
his Destiny my density has brought me to
you in 2000 uk-based ardman animation
best known for its Academy award-winning
stop-motion shorts featuring Wallace and
Gromit branched out into feature films
with chicken run led by a hen named
Ginger and a circus performer rooster
named Rocky the story slated for
Slaughter chicken stage a plan to
literally fly The Coop to Freedom
Chicken Run was a massive hit it earned
227 million dollars at the worldwide box
office making it the top grossing
stop-motion animated movie of all time
English actor Julia sawala probably best
known for her role as Savvy on the cult
favorite britcom absolutely fabulous
voiced ginger in the original chicken
run but when the long-awaited sequel
went into production she was not asked
to return the reason according to sawala
was ageism she wrote in an open letter
posted to Twitter last week I was
informed out of the blue via email
through my agent that I would not be
cast as ginger in the chicken run sequel
the reason they gave is that my voice
now sounds too old and they want a
younger actress to reprise the role
so Walla further noted that she wasn't
even given the opportunity to provide a
voice test to determine if her voice had
indeed changed too much so she did one
herself and sent it to producers who
still opted to get someone else to
portray ginger in the 2023 sequel Mel
Gibson's big break in the film industry
was his star-making role as Max
rocketanski in George Miller's 1979 cult
classic Mad Max the film was a success
in the sequel the road warrior became an
international Sensation that spawned a
wave of copycats and imitators Gibson
reprized the role for that film and Mad
Max Beyond Thunderdome but he was ousted
and replaced by Tom Hardy when it came
time for Mad Max Fury Road at one point
Gibson was set to play Mad Max again in
Fury Road but many years and many
scandals later the plans for the film
changed drastically Miller first had the
idea for Fury Road around the turn of
the century and nearly went into
production in 2001 with Gibson in the
lead role though the events of 9 11
caused the project to stall over a
decade would pass before he got back
around to making Fury Road by the time
Miller was ready to remount the
production Gibson had both aged out of
the role and had gone through all of the
personal scandals that had ravaged his
viability as a leading man
Gibson and Miller had a mutual
understanding about the replacement and
there was no bad blood between them
Gibson even attended the premier of Fury
Road and posed for photos with Miller
and Hardy when director Stephen
Soderberg decided to remake the 1960 Rat
Pack Heist movie Ocean's 11. he
modernized the plot for the 2000s packed
it full of Hollywood's biggest stars of
the time and expanded it into a full
film franchise
in Ocean's 11 Ocean's 12 and Oceans 13
Matt Damon filled the role of Linus
Caldwell with the final film hitting
theaters in 2007. when the franchise
received a spin-off 11 years later in
the form of Ocean's 8 Damon was meant to
reprise his role as Linus in a brief
appearance alongside the new all-female
cast he shot his Cameo but it didn't
make it into the film's Final Cut Carl
Reiner also shot a cameo appearance
reprising his role as Saul Bloom but he
was left on The Cutting Room floor as
well director Gary Ross said the removal
of their cameos came about following
reshoots and an extended editing process
to make the story flow as smoothly as
possible the official reason for cutting
Daemon is innocuous enough but some have
posited that his removal may have been
to avoid backlash the actor had made
public comments defending Harvey
Weinstein which led to an official
petition to have him removed from the
film ahead of its release however Ross
denied that Damon's personal Scandal
influenced the decision to cut him from
the film released in 2021 The Matrix
resurrections was the long delayed
fourth entry in The Matrix series which
had previously concluded with the Matrix
Revolutions in 2003 in the nearly two
decades between the third and fourth
movies there were some significant
changes to the cast but the reasons
behind those changes are perhaps a bit
questionable
stars like Keanu Reeves and Carrie Anne
Moss returned but other prominent
characters were recast including agent
Smith and Morpheus
Hugo weaving was initially supposed to
reprise the agent Smith role but he
ended up getting replaced by Jonathan
Groff the official reason for his
absence was scheduling conflicts owing
to his commitments to the National
Theater weaving was willing to do both
projects as long as his scenes could be
shot a bit later which almost happened
but director Lana Wachowski was
unwilling to accommodate his busy
schedule and opted to recast the role
instead we're willing to wipe the sleet
clean weaving had been open about his
concerns that the Matrix resurrections
might not have been getting made for the
right reasons which may have factored
into the decision to replace it Lawrence
Fishburne on the other hand wasn't
invited to reprise the Morpheus role for
reasons that were never made clear to
him the part instead went to Yaya Abdul
Mateen II Aldous Hodge took on the role
of Carter Hall AKA Hawkman for the first
time in the 2022 DC movie Black Adam
opposite Dwayne The Rock Johnson Hodge
was supposed to play Hawkman for the
second time the following year but that
didn't come to be
his second appearance as Hawkman was
meant to be in Shazam Fury of the Gods a
direct sequel to the first Shazam and
part of the broader DC extended universe
Hawkman was supposed to recruit Shazam
for the Justice Society in the
post-credits scene with all of the
seismic changes a DC recently following
the James Gunn takeover and radical
restructuring of future plot lines and
characters it would be natural to assume
that hawkman's appearance and Shazam
Fury of the Gods was mixed as part of
the same shake-up the truth however is
that the change had nothing to do with
any of that instead the scene was cut at
The Rock's behest the news was confirmed
by Shazam star Zachary Levi who called
out the rock for blocking the Hawkman
Cameo as well as blocking the Shazam
character from a cameo appearance in
Black Adam Levi even appeared to blame
the rock for the box office failure of
Shazam Fury of the Gods although he
later denied doing so
Sin City a deemed to kill for is both a
prequel and sequel to The Original Sin
City this belated follow-up to the
original Anthology features a new cast
of characters alongside many familiar
faces two characters who returned but
were played by different actors were
minute and Dwight recasting minute with
Dennis Haysbert was an unfortunate
necessity after the sad passing of
original actor Michael Clark Duncan the
recasting of Dwight however was a bit
more of a head scratcher originally
played by Clive Owen the role was
instead taken over by Josh Brolin with
his change in appearance justified by
the character undergoing facial
reconstruction surgery to look
completely different but the problem is
that Dwight receives the surgery part
way through a Dame to kill 4 with Roland
donning distracting Prosthetics to make
him look more like Owen it seems like
the perfect setup to have Owen finish
the last stretch of the movie and that
was actually the original plan but
director Robert Rodriguez liked what
Brolin did with the character and
decided to use him for the whole film it
certainly helped that it was cheaper and
easier to just use one actor instead of
two at the old do I go let it go this
old face shortly ahead of shooting Owen
said he had never been asked about
reprising his role as Dwight he told
Indie wire we never really talked about
it with a gargantuan three-hour run time
and the lore from nearly two dozen prior
movies Avengers end game was positively
bursting at the seams with Marvel
characters it makes sense that in such
an overstuffed undertaking there was
bound to be some material left on The
Cutting Room floor one actor who was cut
out of the movie altogether was
Catherine Langford who played a grown-up
version of Tony Stark's daughter Morgan
Stark the character appeared in a vision
to Tony in the latter stages of the film
The deleted scene eventually popped up
on Disney plus accompanied by a
commentary track from directors Anthony
and Joe Russo Joe Russo explained that
the scene was cut for the sake of pacing
in redundancy we felt like a ground the
movie to a halt additionally they spoke
on the pitfalls of making a movie of
this scale stating what can happen in a
film this big is you can have ending
after ending after ending and it starts
to feel like the movie's never going to
end
is part of the ensemble cast of the
original the Lord of the Rings trilogy
Christopher Lee left a huge impression
as the villainous Saruman after playing
a significant role in the plots of The
Fellowship of the Ring and the two
towers Saruman was entirely absent from
the trilogy Capper The Return of the
King this may have come as a surprise to
fans of the series and it most
definitely came as a surprise to Lee
himself Lee shot multiple scenes for the
Return of the King only for his
character's presence in the film to be
excised completely the reason for
saruman's removal was because the
character storyline had been pretty much
wrapped up by the end of The Two Towers
director Peter Jackson planned to
feature him near the beginning of the
third movie for more definitive closure
but this ended up feeling unnecessary it
also harmed the pacing of the film once
it was all edited together Saruman
scenes were later included in the
extended edition of The Return of the
King but Lee was quite upset he was cut
from the theatrical versions for a while
he held a grudge against Jackson but
they were able to smooth things over by
the time the Hobbit trilogy was made as
Lee reprized the Saruman role in both
the first and third movies
before the Marvel Cinematic Universe
became the crown jewel of superhero
films there was the X-Men series while
this franchise of superpower team-ups
hasn't had quite the level of box office
clout as the MCU in recent years it
still did have quite a bit of appeal
that appeal bubbled over from many comic
enthusiasts when Olivia Munn was cast to
play psylocke in X-Men apocalypse plenty
of fans expected mun to return for the
final installment of the 20th Century
Fox X-Men series though that likely had
something to do with mun herself she
proclaimed ahead of time that dark
Phoenix would be a two-parter in that
her character would definitely be making
an appearance the studio didn't take too
kindly to the admission and sent a note
to let her know as much I can't say
anything because last time I said a
little bit
they sent me a note nonetheless the slip
of the tongue wasn't actually the reason
mun didn't return for dark Phoenix
instead the issue was much simpler
scheduling conflicts when the X-Men
saddled up for their final ride at Fox
Munn was busy filming the predator and
was unavailable Evan Peters played the
supporting role of Todd one of the high
school buddies of the titular superhero
in the first kick ass when it came time
to make the sequel three years later
Peters was no longer involved however
Todd was not only still a part of the
plot but he had even more to do the
second time around the role was recast
with Augustus Prue who was best known
for his role in the Borgeous Kick-Ass 2
had a Litany of other eyebrow raising
concerns outside of Peter's recasting so
the actor swap flew further under the
radar than it probably would have
otherwise the movie was met with a far
harsher reception across the board than
the well-liked original and the
situation wasn't aided by the fact that
Jim Carrey who played one of the lead
roles in the sequel went around
denouncing the movie publicly ahead of
its release Peter's absence from
Kick-Ass 2 was chalked up to scheduling
conflicts with the second season of
American Horror Story
strangely he had successfully juggled
another role in a superhero property he
played Pietro maximoff AKA quicksilver
in 2014's X-Men Days of Future Past and
2016's X-Men apocalypse
[Music]